To start let's talk about how you would
network two machines, each with a single interface,
to each other. So Host 1 and Host 2 would be connected by two Ethernet adapters
or network interfaces and each of these would
have a LAN or physical or MAC address.
Now a host that wants to sent a
datagram to another host can simply send that datagram
via its Ethernet adapter with a destination MAC
address of the other host that it wants to
receive the frame. Frames can also be sent to
a broadcast destination MAC address which would mean that
the datagram would be sent to every host
that it was connected to on the local area
network. Now, of course, typically what happens is a
host knows a DNS name or or an IP
address of another host, but it may not know the hardware or MAC address of
the adapter on the host that it wants to send it's datagram to. So we
need to provide a way for a host to learn the MAC address of another
host. The solution to this is a
protocol called ARP or the address resolution protocol.